- Hi, It's Dina.
I'm here with Queer Eye's Tan France
and we're going to have a conversation
about representation on telly.
(atmospheric electronic music)
Do you remember the first time
you ever saw yourself represented
on British television.
- It was not when I was younger,
it was just a little bit younger, 2018.
It was when I represented myself.
There was nobody else when I was younger
that represented people like me.
I never saw a gay Asian on TV before.
We were not the romantic
interest, we were not the lead.
We were not the person
who was seen as desirable.
who was seen as the person
everybody wanted to get,
that wasn't our role.
- Did you feel a certain pressure
knowing that you were stepping
into this role for people.
- Yeah, it's the reason
why I at first didn't think
I wanted to audition for the show.
My husband was actually
the one who convinced me.
He said, "You've been
talking about this for many,
"many years that you've
never seen a version of you
"on screen before, and
now this opportunity's
"presented itself and you're
choosing to turn it down.
"You get to be that version
"of the person you so
desperately craved as a child."
- Why do you think it's important
to have representation on screen?
- Not seeing a version of myself on TV
meant that I wasn't, we weren't,
my people weren't normalized.
I felt like I was alone.
I felt like the life I was
living wasn't appropriate,
that it could be judged.
When you see representation in the media
of those minority groups it
means it's somewhat normalized.
People are starting to understand
not just the stereotype,
not just the caricature of that person,
what they truly represent,
they're seen as humans.
They're seen as real people.
So that's what I think
representation means.
That's what representation
brings to a community
is the sense of normalcy, the
sense that they do belong.
- How far do you think that
the entertainment industry
has come in terms of representation
from when you were a kid in the UK?
- It's come a relatively long way.
- Right.
- You will see more often
a slightly better mix of ethnicities on TV
or people who are gay
or people who are trans.
So a broader range of representation,
but I still don't feel like
it's where it needs to be.
As I said, I'm still one of
the very first to do this,
and it's not like I'm some
obscure race here in the UK.
There's a huge percentage of
the population here in the UK
that is Pakistani, there is
a huge population within that
of Asians in general who are also gay,
yet that is not represented on TV.
So yes, we've come a long
way in certain areas.
It's nowhere where it needs to be still.
- How often do you have
this kind of conversation?
Is it something that, do
you get a fatigue sometimes
having to chat about it?
- No.
- No, okay.
- How come?
- Because I know why I
took this job on Queer Eye.
I wanna do a cute makeover,
don't get me wrong.
It's really fun to play with clothes.
However, I had an agenda
when I took this job.
I wanted to be seen, I
wanted people to see me.
I wanted somebody to
have the balls to say,
you are different and
you don't belong on TV
because you're different.
Now I need you to see
me for everything I am.
And so if it means that people
have to hear this conversation over
and over again and they are sick of it,
I don't care if you're
sick of this conversation,
you need to hear it.
If you're sick of this conversation,
you're the person who needs to hear this.